ist das nun der Versuch die Unruhe und
die Demonstration die ist ja ein ganz
Russland gab in den Griff zu bekommen
oder wie beurteilen Sie das
ich glaube er hat die Kritik schon
aufgenommen weil die Kritik ja auch
öffentlich war was er hier doch auch
ungewöhnlich ist und die Kritik
teilweise auch von Putin Befürwortern
kam und ohne jetzt konkreter darauf
einzugehen hat er diese Kritik
aufgenommen und ich denke mal er wird
selbst auch nicht selber überzeugt und
begeistert davon sein dass es doch dabei
der Rekrutierung einige Probleme gibt
und wir haben verschiedene Berichte
gesehen dass dann verschiedenen Stellen
hat er hat es aufgegriffen weil er
selbst natürlich ein Interesse hat dass
das reibungslos läuft ja es gibt klar
gleich diese Veranstaltung im Kreml
hinter ihnen welche Rolle soll diese
Veranstaltung spielen hoff Putin darauf
dass es wieder eine erneute Welle des
Nationalismus oder zu seiner
Unterstützung gibt oder welche Hoffnung
verbindet er damit
genau wir stehen hier unten am
Ufer der Moskva da sehen wir den Kreml
da wird dann ein paar Minuten diese
Zeremonie starten putin wird die
Verträge unterschreiben die dann die
Zugehörigkeit der vier Gebiete zur
Russischen Föderation besiegeln er wird
dann auch noch eine Rede halten und dann
danach soll hier auf dem Roten Platz das
steht schon die große Bühne soll dann
die große patriotismus-show starten
Wladimir Putin braucht diese Bilder auf
jeden Fall um zu versuchen das russische
Volk mitzunehmen bei dieser Idee und
auch bei der Mobilisierung ob das klappt
ist fraglich es gab heute auch schon
Kritik an dieser Veranstaltung auch von
Putin Unterstützern die sagen das ist
heute nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt diese
Tage das ist nicht der richtige Moment
um zu feiern während russische Soldaten
bei der militärischen spezial-operation
eingekesselt sind und viele Russinnen
und Russen die gucken auch würde ich
sagen sorgenvoll auf diese Rede heute
und auch auf den Auftritt von Putin weil
viele doch Angst haben dass Putin die
Maßnahmen verschärfen könnte
beispielsweise die Grenzen schließen
könnte für Wehrpflichtige und das hat
auch noch mal diese Mobilisierung
an die Grenzen und die Flucht vieler
vieler Russen die eben keine Lust haben
in diesen Konflikt mit reingezogen zu
werden wir haben die Bilder von
verschiedenen Grenzen gesehen das hat
das in den letzten Tagen auf jeden Fall
noch mal befeuert insofern gucken viele
gespannt auf das was Putin hier heute zu
sagen hat vielen Dank nach Moskau für
diese Einschätzungen und wir schalten
gleich weiter nach Kiew zu Wasili gollot
was bedeutet die Einverleibung des
ukrainischen Gebietes durch Russland an
diesem Tag für Kiew
das bedeutet einen erneuten einen
weiteren Tabubruch die Ukraine kennt das
die Ukraine kennt das Verfahren der
Annexion das ist bereits passiert 2014
mit der völkerrechtswidrigen Annexion
der ukrainischen Halbinsel Krim und das
was jetzt passiert ist eine Wiederholung
dessen in noch schlimmerer Form aus
ukrainischer Sicht weil parallel dieser
brutale Krieg wütet wir haben es ja im
Beitrag eingangs gesehen heute wurden
beim Angriff auf saporicia mindestens 25
Menschen getötet mehr als 70 wurden
verletzt das alles ist die Realität das
alles ist diese kriegsrealität mit der
die Menschen leben und deswegen ist die
Haltung sowohl der Gesellschaft als auch
der Politik das ist alternativlos ist
für die Ukraine dieses besetzte Gebiet
wie auch immer Russland das dann nennt
annektiert oder nicht annektiert wieder
zu befreien zu Realität dieses Krieges
gehört ja auch das Russland mit
Atomwaffen droht nun wird ja in
Deutschland aber auch ich glaube in ganz
Europa viel über diese nukleare Optionen
der Russen gesprochen inwieweit ist das
Thema in der Ukraine
es gab heute ein Treffen des Stabs der
das obersten Befehlshabers selensky hat
da den engsten Zirkel zusammengeholt die
die militärischen Fragen entscheiden ich
bin mir sicher dass diese Frage dort
auch diskutiert wurde ich selbst war in
einer Apotheke um mir ein Bild davon zu
machen habe die Apothekerin gefragt wie
es dann aussieht mit dem Verkauf von
Jodtabletten hier in Kiew in der
Hauptstadt sie sagte mir es nimmt sehr
zu in den vergangenen Tagen und was sie
beunruhige ist dass viele Polizisten und
viele Soldaten sich auch diese
Jodtabletten kaufen das heißt es ist auf
jeden Fall ein Thema in der Ukraine und
dennoch ändert das nichts an der
Grundhaltung die Menschen erleben eine
Invasion seit dem 24 februar eine
russische Invasion und die einzige
Möglichkeit so ist hier die Haltung sich
dagegen zu wehren ist die militärische
denn russland hat mit dem Schritt dieser
Annektion ein weiteres Mal deutlich
gemacht dass eine diplomatische Lösung
nicht im Interesse des Kreml ist ja
Stichwort militärische Optionen die UK
melden weiterhin Erfolge so steht
jedenfalls ist es nachzulesen in den
Agenturmeldungen Liman im Osten des
Landes offenbar vor der Befreiung durch
die Ukraine was würde das denn für Kiew
bedeuten wenn es wirklich vielleicht
auch noch ausgerechnet an diesem Tag
heute wo Moskau da feiert dazu käme
das wäre ein sehr wichtiger
militärischer Erfolg im Mann liegt in
der Region dann jetzt das ist eine
Region die für Russland strategisch sehr
sehr wichtig ist die Russland immer
wieder als zentrales Ziel ausgegeben hat
diese Region zu befreien wie es aus
russischer Sicht immer heißt nach
derzeitigem informationsstadt ist
eingekesselt das ist schon mal ein
großer militärischer Schritt und der
nächste Schritt wäre eben die Befreiung
das wäre für die Moral der Gesellschaft
enorm wichtig und das wäre militärisch
ein sehr sehr großer Erfolg wenn es
ausgerechnet an diesem Tag an dem Tag an
dem Putin diese feierliche aus seiner
Sicht Zeremonie durchführt im Kreml
passiert dann wäre das auch eine große
Niederlage für Russland Herr golot danke
für diese Erläuterung danke für Ihre
Zeit nach Kiew und im Phoenix Studio in
Bonn begrüße jetzt Udo lischkis denn
langjährigen russland-korrespondenten
der ARD herzlich willkommen bei Phoenix
wir können gleich mal zusammen auf das
Bild Moskau schauen da scheint ja die
gesamte
norman-klatura versammelt zu sein in
diesem offensichtlicher herrschaftlich
herrlichen Saal im Kreml das virtuelle
lischkis aber nichts daran ändern dass
die militärische Lage wir haben gerade
den Kollegen gehört in der Ostukraine
für die Russen weiterhin eine ganz
fürchterliche ist denn man liest drei
bis 5000 russische Soldaten könnten dort
im Osten eingeschlossen sein also könnte
noch ein bitterer Tag für Putin werden
oder kann sein hört oder liest dass es
heute Nacht passieren könnte aber auch
wenn es morgen passiert auf jeden Fall
ist das eine ganz angespannte Situation
zumal Liman auf strategisch ein ganz
wichtiger Ort ist weil dadurch die
Kontrolle auch über wichtige
Eisenbahnlinien also Nachschubwege der
russischen Armee weiter in die Hand der
Ukraine kämen und damit würde auch der
Vormarsch in Richtung lochansk
erleichtert das ist eine ganz
bedrohliche Situation
wir schauen mal auf die Bilder aus
Moskau also ich habe schon sagte gesamte
normenklatura scheint dort versammelt zu
sein scheuko habe ich gesehen den
verteilungsminister lavrov ist auch
schon gesichtet worden hier links ist ja
der erste Vertreter der Separatisten
das ist der das politische Oberhaupt der
sogenannten Volksrepublik dann jetzt
einer nicht anerkannten internationalen
Volksrepublik und die anderen drei
werden daneben sitzen da denke ich mal
die vier Herren haben schon gesagt Sie
wollen auch in Moskau bleiben heute wird
ja als erster Schritt die Urkunde
unterzeichnet die annektionsurkunde aber
dann muss das Verfassungsgericht sich
noch äußern zu dieser Aufnahme dieser
vier Gebiete und die beiden kann man das
Parlaments also die Duma und der
Föderationsrat müssen zustimmen nun
ahnen wir beide dass das reibungslos
funktionieren wird weil die Justiz seit
vielen vielen Jahren ja ein willfähriges
Werkzeug des Kreml geworden ist und das
Parlament ebenso also ich glaube da
würde niemand große Summen setzen
überwecken wollen
die man dort sieht im Kreml ein paar
Damen sind auch dort aber in der
Mehrzahl sind es Herren was hören sie
denn aus Russland wie geschlossen ist
denn der Inner Circle wie gesagt
geschlossen steht er hinter Putin noch
das ist schwer zu sagen weil Mitglieder
der sogenannten Elite Russlands werden
den Teufel tun und sich laut gegen
Potenz Pläne in der Ukraine äußern es
gibt so kleine Duftmarken man merkt zum
Beispiel dass der Moskauer Bürgermeister
nicht mehr so hinter dieser Z Propaganda
steht die ist weniger geworden in Moskau
man bemerkt dass zum Beispiel der
Ministerpräsident Beschuss Hinsicht noch
nicht geäußert hat zu Ukraine das sind
dann so kleine Duftnoten wenn Sie so
wollen dass es da sehr wohl Menschen
gibt dieser kritisch über das ganze
denken es gibt ja auch wie Sie wissen
alle ganz bekannte pop-diba hat sich
dagegen ausgesprochen aber es sind
wenige die das so mutig tun es gab mal
vor einiger Zeit ein sehr spannenden
Artikel von jewgenia Albas das ist eine
sehr mutige Putin kritische
Herausgeberin eines eines einer Zeitung
an der Online-Zeitung die hervorragende
Kontakte in die Elite hat und die
erzählte dann und berichteten ihrer in
ihrem Artikel dass sie die meisten auf
Parkbänken in Parks getroffen hat da
durfte niemand was mitkriegen die haben
große große Angst ihre Meinung zu sagen
aber wenn sie dann glauben sie können
anonym reden dann klang das alles nicht
sehr wohlwollend also ich glaube es ist
nicht zu spekulativ zu sagen dass doch
ein Teil der Elite das ganze sehr
kritisch steht und der Grund ist völlig
klar mit diesen historischen Bewegungen
die ganze Welt verschrecken zerstört
Putin auch das Geschäftsmodell seiner
Eliten und diese Elite die wir da jetzt
live aus dem Kreml sehen und im kremme
sehen die wartet darauf dass der
Machthaber Putin gleich erscheint und
dann die sogenannte
annexionsurkunde unterzeichnet wir
wollen das Ganze live übertragen und
dann hier auch einordnen aus dem Phönix
Studio das könnte so oder so ein
Weltereignis werden das weiß man nicht
je nachdem wie die Geschichte sich
entwickelt wenn sich die Geschichte so
für Putin entwickelt könntest du auch
ein wichtiger Meilenstein werden Kiew
spricht übrigens
eine Zitat Freakshow die der stattfinden
würde heute in Moskau und mehr als
260.000
Bürgerinnen und Bürger vor allem
Russlands sind offensichtlich der
gleichen Meinung denn die haben
Mobilisierung anders verstanden indem
sie sich vom Acker gemacht haben auf
deutsch gesagt das Land verlassen haben
gestern musste er bezugnehmen darauf
Putin vor diesem Hintergrund dieser man
kann ja schon fast sagen Massenflucht
ist das ein Problem für ihn mit
Sicherheit Putin hat letztlich durch
diese Mobilisierung eine Art Vertrag
aufgekündigt den er geschlossen hatte
mit der großen schweigenden mehr als
eine Bevölkerung nämlich der ist
sinngemäß lasst uns hier unsere
nationalistischen hurra patriotischen
Dinge tun und ihr dürft dafür weiter
privat bleiben genießt euer Privatleben
ihr werdet das kaum merken dass wir da
Krieg führen und diesen
stillschweigenden Vertrag hat er
natürlich dramatisch gebrochen weil
jetzt mit fast jede Familie über die
Gefahren die erdrohen weil der Sohn der
Vater der Onkel wer auch immer an die
Front muss in der Ukraine ist es
tatsächlich so während wir gerade ja die
Bilder der unterschiedlichen Religionen
und Ethnien aus Moskau sehen ist es
tatsächlich so dass jetzt auch die
Metropolen sprich ST petersburg und
Moskau betroffen sind oder ist das in
der Mehrzahl immer noch die Provinz das
wird immer noch die Mehrzahl sein aber
jetzt schlägt der Blitz auch in den
großen Städten an das hat er bisher fast
peinlich vermieden wenn sie die Stadt
Statistiken der gefallenen russischen
Soldaten anschauen haben sie eine
Relation von 1 zu was nicht 200
teilweise zwischen dagistan etwa das ist
so eine ethnische Gruppierung die
boriaden haben sehr stark geblutet jetzt
aktuell seit dem 24 nein also bis
vor der Mobilisierung ja da konnten sie
klar sehen dass Putin peinlich darauf
achtete dass die großen Städte
petersburg und Moskau davon verschont
Bremen und das klappte auch meine Frau
war im Sommer dort noch bei ihren bei
ihrer Familie in Moskau merkte man fast
nichts von diesem Krieg und das war auch
potenziell aber jetzt merkt man es
natürlich sehr wohl jetzt laufen die
Leute weg aus Moskau während diese
Herren sehen fällt mir ein sie haben es
auch schon angetextet fast in jeder
Familie wird jetzt diskutiert und vor
allem auch die Mütter machen sich
natürlich Sorgen über ihre Söhne die
Frauen über ihre Männer aber auch die
Mütter über ihre Söhne ich habe gelesen
wenn die Mütter auf die Straße gehen in
Russland dann würde es für die
Machthaber gefährlich werden war das
schon mal in der Geschichte Russland so
wo die Mütter dann tatsächlich was
bewegt und verändern konnten ja
natürlich es gibt die russischen
Soldaten Mütter das waren Vereinigung
die haben im ersten Tschetschenienkrieg
wirklich Furore gemacht weil da sind
tausende dieser Mütter als Konvoi nach
Tschetschenien marschiert um ihre Söder
zurückzubringen da hatten ja auch ein
riesen Gewicht auch im zweiten
Tschetschenienkrieg waren die Soldaten
Mütter noch eine wichtige Kraft die
halfen verschollene Soldaten wieder zu
finden werden sich gegen Behandlung und
so weiter die hat putil absolut
ruhiggestellt
das hat gerade noch mal Volker
ganuschkina gesagt die auch dort
involviert war diese Gruppierung sind
ausländische Agenten geworden das heißt
Sie können gar nicht mehr arbeiten und
sagen das auch ganz offen wir können
nicht mehr riskieren hier Beratung zu
machen die sind alle ruhig gestellt
worden auf dieser
institutionellen Ebene was jetzt die
Dinge vor Ort angeht auch in Jakutien
waren es viele Frauen die sagten lasst
unsere Söhne in Ruhe in dageistan war es
sehr viele Frauen und die an vorderster
Freund demonstrierten das könnte noch
mehr werden wobei ich auch da ein
bisschen irgendwelch dämpfen muss die
die optimistischen Erwartungen left gut
Koch das ist der Direktor des bekannten
levada-instituts eines
Meinungsforschungsinstituts der seit
Jahrzehnten im Grunde als Soziologe
versucht die Stimmungslagen in der
Bevölkerung rauszukriegen der sagt das
Problem ist die wenigsten Menschen haben
Zugang zu guten information Funktionen
vier bis zehn Prozent nur der Rest wird
Bescheid von der Staatspropaganda es
gibt vielleicht 15 Prozent die wirklich
gegen den Krieg sind für die meisten ist
dieser Krieg eine unbekannte Geschichte
die wissen gar nicht was da genau
passiert und konsumieren dann diese
Parolen da da ermorden Kiel über
Faschisten unsere armen
russischsprachigen Mitbürgern und das
ist das Problem aktuell hören wir aus
der Ukraine von Ukrainern das schon die
ersten sogenannten Reservisten gefallen
sind also auf der russischen Seite
gefallen sind und interessanterweise
kommt aus der Ukraine der O-Ton das wäre
so also dieser Kampf zwischen den
Kämpfern der Ukraine und den Reservisten
aus Russland als wenn ein Profiboxer
gegen ein schuljung kämpfen würde jetzt
muss man natürlich sagen das kann auch
ein guter Propaganda sein was darin
enthalten ist aber jetzt die Frage die
werden ja jetzt wahrscheinlich zu
Tausenden dort reingeschmissen an die
Front verlegt möglicherweise stehen
hinten irgendwelche Offiziere die
Maschinenpistolen damit sie nicht
abhauen welchen militärischen Zweck soll
das Erfüllen naja der Versuch ist
sicherlich den den dramatischen
Personalmangel in der russischen Armee
zu beheben also die die großen Löcher
die es dort gibt auch in den
professionellen Einheiten zu stopfen nur
was konkret passiert ist natürlich um
das wissen wir auch was unzähligen
Handyvideos ist natürlich eine eine
schreckliche
unprofessionelle
Ausrüstung dieser Leute da haben sie ja
zischbilder gesehen mit uralt
verrosteten kalaschnikowski haben keine
ordentliche Kleidung der Winter kommt ja
die meisten werden sich die Füße
abfrieren da das sind untrainierte Leute
die teilweise jetzt innerhalb von
Tagesfrist dorthin geschickt wurden und
man muss wirklich davon ausgehen dass es
ihnen ähnlich ergehen wird wie den
zwangsrekrutierten aus den
Volksrepubliken da haben wir ja schon
mal so eine Art Beispiel wie es geht in
den Republiken dann jetzt und nur Hans
wurden ja Männer auf der Straße
eingefangen und in den Krieg geschickt
ohne großes Training und die hatten
enorme Quoten von bis zu 80 Prozent das
heißt das war ein Schlachtfest und
ähnlich muss man wohl endlich muss man
wohl erwarten jetzt bei diesen
russischen
mobilisierten die dahin geschickt werden
liebe Zuschauer Udo ist analysiert für
uns die aktuelle Situation rund um den
Ukraine Krieg während wir auf den Beginn
der Veranstaltung im Kreml warten die
sogenannte Unterzeichnung dieser
annexionsurkunden die da heute
vorgenommen wird wir haben noch ein
bisschen Zeit wir haben ja gelernt Putin
lässt die anderen ganz gerne warten in
der Vergangenheit war das schon so in
jüngster Vergangenheit hat sich das
geändert bei dem einen oder anderen
internationalen Treffen musste er dann
warten heute ist er Chef der
Veranstaltung sobald es dort losgeht
werden wir live in den Kreml schalten
und das auch an reden übertragen was ist
zu übertragen gibt dieses riesige Land
Russland 9000 Kilometer
Ausdehnung das größte Land der Erde
steht da diesem Land
reine gegenüber auch für unsere
Verhältnisse auch ein großes Land 1700
Kilometer
Ost-West-Ausdehnung ich glaube ist das
größte Land was vollständig auf dem
Territorium Europas erlegt jetzt haben
wir schon mehr als 200 Tage genau gesagt
219 Tage dieses Krieges die Ukrainer
sind in der Lage die Russen
zurückzuschlagen
man hat den Eindruck der ist das was am
Anfang so ein bisschen nach
Durchhalteparolen Klang wir holen uns
unsere besetzen Gebiete wieder dass das
tatsächlich realisiert werden könnte wie
überraschend ist es für Sie
doch das ist überraschend ich werde mich
ja gut an die ersten Tage und Wochen
dieses Krieges wo einfach nur mehrere
immer wieder auch demonstriert wurde
welche Überlegenheit die Russen hatten
im Bereich der Luftwaffe der Artillerie
das waren ja Relationen von 1 zu 10 und
1 zu 15 da musste man eigentlich als
außenstehender Beobachter davon ausgehen
dass das letztlich nicht sehr
chancenreich ist aber dann haben sich
dann noch sehr sehr schnell dramatische
Fehler gezeigt auf russischer Seite
angefangen natürlich von dem von der
unfassbaren fehlereinschätzung man
können dort in die Ukraine kommen und
innerhalb weniger Tage ein Regimewechsel
herstellen man werde von Teilen der
Bevölkerung erst recht in den
russischsprachigen Städten die radikive
würde man sozusagen mit Blumen empfangen
da hatten ja viele Offiziere ihre Parade
Uniform schon eingepackt
das ist bemerkenswert aber muss man kurz
nachdenken wie kann es sein dass ein
Aggressor im Nachbarland
eine solche krasse fehlereinschätzung
vornimmt Putin hat einen unfassbar
großen aufgeblähten Geheimdienst da wird
dieselbe Sprache gesprochen ja und da
haben wir natürlich sehr schnell lernen
müssen dass er offenbar so isoliert ist
in seinem Elfenbeinturm in seinem
historischen studierenkämmerchen dass
seine Umgebung ihm gar nicht mehr die
wahren Dinge erzählen zu erzählen wagt
es gibt so Briefe aus dem Inneren des
das Geheimnis des FSB
viele halten die für authentisch wo das
auch ganz gut beschrieben wird das a
werden nicht die Analysen bestellt bei
den Spezialisten die man eigentlich
brauchte und die die bestellt werden
werden auf dem Weg durch die Instanzen
bis zum Präsidenten so zurecht gehobelt
dass er am Ende das liest was er auch
erwartet zu lesen anders kann man das ja
gar nicht erklären wie können Sie eine
so dramatische fehlanschätzung eines
anzugreifenden Landes sonst und heute
führt der angeblicher sogar höchst
selbst was das Schlachtfeld angeht das
Kommando darüber können wir vielleicht
gleich sprechen wir schauen erst ein
wenig auf den Gegenpart in Kiew auf
selenski den ukrainischen Präsidenten
denn der hat sich in der letzten Nacht
an die Bürger Russlands genau gesagt an
die kaukasischen Bürger Russlands
gewarnt und hat sie aufgefordert die
Waffen niederzulegen nicht den
Militärdienst anzutreten warum aus dem
Bereich Kaukasien weil von dort offenbar
besonders viele Eliteeinheiten kommen
nun befinde ich mich in dem Teil Kiews
wo
1880 ein Held lebte ein Held aus
dagistan und des ganzen Kaukasus immer
am schamin wie Sie sehen kann die
Ukraine eure Helden würdigen wir
behalten das Gedenken an sie und auch an
die Orte die die Kulturen unserer Völker
zusammengebracht haben das ist das
Epizentrum unserer Hauptstadt eines der
hunderte ukrainischer Städte gegen die
die russische Regierung Raketen richtet
Bomben und auch das Militär der Kaukasus
weiß was das bedeutet der Kaukasus hat
das gesehen
schon 218 Jahre verteidigen wir uns
gegen die die mehr Raketen und Menschen
haben als wir doch diese Menschen sind
gemein und niederträchtig das ist ein
niederträchtiger Krieg das ist ein
Verbrechen und wir tun tolles um unsere
Menschen zu schützen und auch die
Unabhängigkeit der Ukraine dass es
unsere heilige Pflicht und unsere
Aufgabe unsere Pflicht vor unseren
Eltern eine Pflicht vor unseren Kindern
eine Pflicht gegenüber allen
Generationen unseres Volkes diejenigen
die gelebt haben und die leben werden
auf unserem Landesgebiet auf unserem
Landesgebiet wir wollen keine fremden
Gebiete
58,5000 russische Soldaten sind bereits
in der Ukraine gefallen sie sind ja
gekommen um uns zu töten und sind selbst
gestorben
sie hören diese Zahlen nicht man lügt
sie an man sagt nur 6000 sind etwa
gestorben
58.500 das ist die Wahrheit sie alle
sind gestorben weil ein einziger Mensch
diesen Krieg gewollt hat nur ein Mensch
und viele dienen diese Menschen die
Völker Kaukasus des Kaukasus alle Völker
in Russland sie haben keinen einzigen
Grund um unter diesen vielen sein die
immer noch diesem einen dienen der
diesen Krieg will sie dürfen nicht töten
ihre Söhne dürfen nicht in Ukraine töten
sie haben nicht diese Pflicht und auch
nicht diese Aufgabe nicht gegenüber
ihren Vätern oder Ihren Kindern und auch
nicht gegenüber ihrer Zukunft oder der
Zukunft ihres Landes und das wissen sie
auch wir sehen das ja soweit Präsident
silenski aus Kiew und jetzt hat Wladimir
Putin der Machthaber in Moskau die Bühne
betreten und wenn es sich jetzt nun an
die Versammlung nur ganz genau
anderen Republiken Bürger der saporisier
Republik und
Abgeordneten der Stadt dummer und der
des Parlaments der Russischen Föderation
und jetzt und so ganz Republik von
herson Gebiet die Referenten sind
stattgefunden die Ergebnisse der
Referenten haben es bestätigt wir kennen
sie Ergebnisse die Menschen haben ihre
Wahl getroffen
eindeutig eine eindeutige Entscheidung
heute unterschreiben wir die Verträge
für den Eintritt von Donezk
Volksrepublik
saporosgebiet Lugansk Volksrepublik zum
weitere zur Russischen Föderation ich
bin sicher dass die föderalversammlung
das auch bestätigen würde wir Grünen
vier neue Subjekte der Föderation für
neue Subjekte in der Russischen
Föderation weil das ist ein Willen von
Millionen von Menschen
[Applaus]
das ist natürlich
deren Recht
deren recht was verankert ist dem
Artikel 1 von UNO
Karte
Gleichberechtigung und Selbstbestimmung
der Völker
noch einmal das ist deren Recht
historisch bedingt auf der
von Generationen von unseren Ahnen
von Russland über Jahrhunderte hinweg
ist das
begrenzt worden und hier in Neu Russland
oschakova und unter also die zweite und
die anderen haben hier Städtegründungen
gemacht haben das Land weiterentwickelt
unsere Väter und Großväter haben das
Land verteidigt während des Zweiten
Vaterländischen Krieg ist im Zweiten
Weltkrieg ist das sind unsere Helden die
2014 es nicht aufgegeben
2014 haben wir es nicht zugegeben wie in
dem neonazir journalistischen umstoß in
der Ukraine wir wollen mit denen halten
die ihre Kultur aufhalten wollen die ihr
Recht auf das Leben auferhalten wollen
das ist Donbass das sind die Martyrer
von Odessa das sind die
Matura von den unzähligen
und Daten vom kieferschirm das sind
russische Russen utukrainer Männer
Frauen und Kinder das sind Menschen von
unterschiedlichen
Generationen Sacher
und die anderen sind die Kampf
kommandiere da sind diejenigen für die
Unabhängigkeit von tanjesko und Lukas
gekämpft haben das ist der magometrische
das sind unsere Soldaten und Offiziere
die umgekommen sind in dieser
sonderoperation die sind Helden
von dem großen Russland und ich bitte
Sie mit dieser Schweigeminute deren
Andenken zu würdigen
so das war schon mal die erste ich sag
jetzt mal herrlich ist Schicht von
Propaganda die davon Putin kam in dem er
sagte die Menschen in den Regionen in
diesen vier oblasten der Ukraine hätten
sie teilt ihre Wahl getroffen und er
beruft sich tatsächlich auf die
Selbstbestimmung denn jetzt
unsere gemeinsames Schicksal und
tausendjährige Geschichte diese geistige
Verbindung haben die Menschen an ihre
Kinder und Enkelkinder vererbt
ungeachtet aller Schwierigkeiten haben
sie das über Jahre bewahrt diese Liebe
zu Russland und dieses Gefühl kann
niemand in uns zerstören
darum ist es so dass die älteren
Generationen auch die Jugend diejenigen
die nach der Tragödie deshalb falls der
Sowjetunion geboren sind für unsere
Einigkeit gestimmt haben für unsere
gemeinsame Zukunft
1901 war es so dass in
da wurden jetzt will es nicht gefragt
und die Vertreter der Partei Eliten
hatten die Entscheidungen getroffen die
Sowjetunion kollabieren zu lassen und
viele Menschen waren abgetrennt von
ihrer Heimat das hat tatsächlich
unsere volkseinigkeit zerstört das war
eine nationale Katastrophe wie einst
nach der Revolution da wurden
willkürlich Grenzen gezogen und die
letzten Führungskräfte der Sowjetunion
haben ja gegen der Willenserklärung
gegen die Referenten 1991 haben Sie
unser großes Land zerstört
und sie haben einfach nur Tatsachen
geschaffen für die Völker ich gebe zu
und lasse es zu dass sie bis zum Ende
nicht ganz verstanden haben was sie tun
und was das für Folgen haben würde
letztendlich aber das ist nicht mehr
wichtig die Sowjetunion gibt es nicht
mehr die Vergangenheit kann nicht
zurückgeholt werden aber Russland ist
heute ja auch nicht mehr daran
interessiert wir streben das nicht an
aber es gibt nichts stärkeres als die
Willenskraft von Millionen von Menschen
die nach Iran nach ihrer Kultur Glauben
ihrer Sprache ihren Traditionen sich
selbst als Teil Russlands sehen
ihre Ahnen haben über Jahrhunderte in
einem Staat gelebt es gibt nichts
stärkeres als die Willenskraft dieser
Menschen zurückzukehren in ihre Wahrheit
wahre historische Heimat und ihr
Vaterland lange acht Jahre war es so
dass die Menschen einem Genozid und
Beschuss und Blockaden und
unterlegen waren und es war ein
verbrechensakt Hass zu Russland und
allem russischen wo denen ihnen geschürt
im Laufe der Referenten hat das KiWa
Regime mit Tod gedroht an für Frauen
eine Lehrer und allen die in den
Kommissionen arbeiten sie haben mit
Repressionen Millionen von Menschen
verängstigt die ihren Willen kundtun
wollten aber nicht gebrochen sind
ähnliche Person in Don Bass in der
Pariser sie haben ihren Willen geäußert
ich möchte dass die KiWa Regierung hören
und die waren Herrscher im Westen damit
alle daran denken die Menschen die in
lung Hans gehen
unsere Bürgerinnen und Bürger für immer
[Applaus]
wir rufen Tiefe regis7 dazu auf weil die
sämtliche Kriegshandlungen einzustellen
den Krieg das entfesselt wurde seit 2014
sofort auch zu hören und wir rufen zu
Verhandlungstisch auf wir sind bereit
wir haben schon mehrfach davon
gesprochen aber die Entscheidung von
doniewski und luganski
ist eine weitere Bestätigung dafür dass
es sind getroffen Russland ist da
[Applaus]
die heutigen Kiew gemacht habe müssen
mit Achtung das betrachten was die
Willensäußerung von den Menschen drüben
angeht nicht anders wir werden
verteidigen unsere Erde unseren Boden
mit allen uns zur Verfügung stehenden
Mittel und wir werden alles dafür tun
und mein sicheres Leben für unsere
Bürger zu gewährleisten das ist unserer
große
Mission oder wir werden alles aufbauen
Schulen
Museen Krankenhäuser wir werden die
Industrie wieder aufbauen und entwickeln
die Infrastruktur die soziale
Absicherung die Renten Absicherung das
werden wir alles übernehmen und alles
weiterentwickeln wir beziehungsweise
wiederherstellen natürlich
entsprechenden
Sicherheitsvorgaben natürlich müssen
unsere neue Mitbürger in den Regionen
spüren unsere Unterstützung von allen
Republiken von unserem großen Russland
die müssen da die gleiche Sicherheit
genießen
liebe Freunde und Kollegen heute spreche
ich auch die Soldaten und Offizieren
Anna die an der sonderoperation
beteiligt sind an den Kämpfern in Don
Bass und
luganski Mobilisierung das ist eine ganz
große Frage die viele Menschen erfüllen
ihre patriotische Pflicht die kommen die
melden sich von alleine an den
Kommissionen und ich spreche jetzt deren
Frauen und deren Mütter an gegen Bahn
gegen wen oder wofür die kämpfen
diese Tragödie ist eine ganz wichtige
eine ganz große unserer Mitbürger in der
Ukraine das ist ein Teil von unserem
gleichen Volk die sehen es mit eigenen
Augen weil die sogenannte
die
westlichen Regierungen kämpfen gegen uns
und wir die haben es damit gezeigt nach
der
reserviertungen wir alle für immer
müssen die dachten wir müssen uns damit
abfilmen mit diesem Diktat von Westen
aber die haben damit gerechnet dass
Russland nach den Erschütterungen nicht
wieder aufkommen will und komplett
zerfallen wird von alleine so ist
beinahe gekommen beinahe in den 90er
Jahren in den schlimmen 90er Jahren in
den Hungerjahren von Russland aber
Russland ist
gestanden es ist auch gestärkt aus der
Krise rausgekommen ist es wieder da es
ist wieder entstanden und ist hat eine
neue Chance jetzt wird der Westen noch
mal die Chance nutzen um Russland wieder
zu schwächen das wollten die schon immer
unser Land zerfallen zu lassen unser
Land zu zerspricht zersplittern unser
Volk dazu zu verdonnern zu verhungern in
Hunger Not zu verrecken aber unser Land
mit ihren in diesem wunderbaren Volk mit
der Natur dass wir werden uns nie beugen
wir werden immer
überall schreiten wir werden alles tun
wenn wir wir dieses neue koloniale
System das brasilierung
mit der Macht von Dollar das dagegen
werden wir alles tun wir werden die
wollen einfach an den sources an den
an der Rente und Hegemonie von unserem
Land profitieren aber wir werden dagegen
Streben deswegen
das ist die Aggression gegen
das ist erklärt die Aggression gegen
traditionelle Kulturen und
gingen sie internationalen
Integrationsprozesse gegen die neuen
Währungen und die neuen technologischen
Entwicklungen
extrem wichtig für die der mit allen
Länder ihre an die USA alles abgeben was
sie an an gutes da haben freiwillig am
liebsten freiwillig
freiwillig sich zu was Zahlen zu
untergeordneten zurückgelegt haben wenn
es nicht freiwillig geht dann werden
ganze Stadt zerstört damit ich hinter
den humanitärer Katastrophen übrig
bleiben und Millionen von zerstörten
Menschenleben
an klaren
zonenprotektorate zum von sozialem
leiden und so weiter es ist aber den
egal den geht es darum dass sie ihren
Profit bekommen ich möchte noch mal
unterschreiben unterstreichen
Bestreben deren unbegrenzte Macht zu
erhalten das ist der einzige Grund von
diesem Hybriden Krieg der der Westen
gerade gegen Russland führt sie wollen
für uns keine Freiheit die wollen uns
als Glauben sehen die wollen keine frei
Gleichberechtigung wir wollen ausräubern
sie wollen keine Gesellschaft sie wollen
eine Sklaven heute
die wollen
keine Philosophie akzeptieren
ich appelliere zurück an unserer Kultur
und unsere Philosophie unsere
Entwicklung und unserer florieren das
ist den scheißegal
es geht nicht um Russland Russland
brauchen die nicht wir brauchen ein
Russland
[Applaus]
ich möchte Ihnen noch einmal eine
Erinnerung rufen die
Welt am Beziehungen sind schon einmal
zersplittert aufgrund unserer Stärke
Russland wird immer Russland bleiben wir
werden auch unsere Werte bewahren und
auch unsere Heimat Schützen der Westen
rechnet damit dass es straflos bleiben
wird das alles einfach straflos
passieren würde so wie auch in der
Vergangenheit die Abkommen in der
strategischen Sicherheit landenden
Mülleimer alle Vereinbarungen die
erzielt wurden auf höchster politischer
Ebene werden als Lügen dargestellt die
festen versprechen die NATO gegen Osten
nicht zu erweitern und unsere ehemaligen
führenden Politiker haben das gekauft
aber das ist auch eine Lüge die Verträge
zu Atomraketen und Mittelstreckenraketen
wurden einseitig unter erfundenen
Vorwänden wieder gestoppt das hören wir
der Westen schützte die Weltordnung
woher kommen werden wer hat denn
überhaupt diese Regeln gesehen wer hat
das abgestimmt hören Sie doch einmal das
ist doch Wahnsinn das ist blödsinn
das sind nur Lügen Doppelmoral oder
vielleicht sogar dreifachmoral die
rechnen wohl dass sie mit Dummkopf zu
tun haben Russland ist ein
tausendjähriges reich an der
Zivilisation und das sind aber falsche
Regeln die das Land niemals akzeptieren
wird
[Applaus]
die unversicherheit der Grenzen bestimmt
und jetzt will ist entscheiden wer hat
Recht auf Selbstbestimmung und wer hat
kein Recht auf Selbstbestimmung wer das
nicht würdig ist wer wieso warum wir
hatten entschieden wer hat das Recht für
die gegeben die haben es sich selbst
dieses Recht zugeschustert deswegen
diese Entscheidung in krimlogans
Küsschen was Doppel und so weiter
deswegen es gibt keine sind sie so
empört weil es gibt überhaupt keine
Moral und Demokratie spielt dabei keine
Rolle sie haben keine Ahnung davon die
westlichen Bürger wollen keine
Entscheidung der Völker akzeptieren
deren Entscheidung hat ein eindeutige
Totalitarismus Touch die wollen deren
was Zahlen von dem sogenannten zivilis
anderen Ländern die teilen die Menschen
auf die Länder auf in zivilisiert und
nie zivilisierter nach irgendeinem
Schlüssel den nötigen
die bekleben das mit bestimmten
sagen zu kompletten Völkern
und daran ist nichts Neues die
westlichen Eliten waren so und sehen so
geblieben die sind kolonisatorisch die
diskriminieren die teilen die Völker in
die erste Klasse und die anderen aber
wir haben es nie angenommen akzeptiert
und wir werden dieses national
kolonialistische Beziehung zu Russland
mir akzeptiert und wir werden es nicht
akzeptieren weiter
es bezieht sich jetzt auf die ganze Welt
was ist es anders als Rassismus was der
Westen sagt dieses dass die neoliberale
kultur ist ein Muss für die ganze Welt
warum wieso
merkwürdig dass Du hören
auch wenn wir beichten unserer
historischen Verbrechen das auf die
anderen zu beziehen das zu beziehen auf
die Bürger von anderen Ländern und
anderer Länder dass die dafür
beichten müssen was die anderen nicht
gemacht haben das bezieht sich auf das
koloniale Vergangenheit also der Westen
hat seine koloniale Politik doch im
Westen ange noch im Mittelalter
angefangen es geht um Sklavenhandel es
geht um die zerplünderung von Indien um
Afrika es geht um Kämpfe von Frankreich
gegen Indien und China
es geht um Opium Handel es sind ganz
viele Sachen sind ganze Völker
abhängig gemacht worden ganze Ethnien
sind vernichtet worden durch diese
Abhängigkeit von bestimmten Drogen es
war ein kompletter menschenhandelt
Menschen jagt wir gegen Tiere gewesen
wäre also es ist nichts um Freiheit und
Gerechtigkeit wir sind stolz darauf dass
gerade unser Land im 20 Jahrhundert
dieses antikoloniale Bestreben angeführt
hat dass den Weg gewesen hat den anderen
Völkern wir können besiegen den Hunger
und andere Leiden einst den Gründen der
von russophobie und da das bösheiten der
westlichen liegen Eliten gegenüber
Russland geht liegt daran dass wir es
nicht erlaubt haben uns in diesem
neo-kolonialen nicht erlaubt haben uns
zu berauben wir haben den Europäern das
auferhängt
Russland zu akzeptieren mit diesem
starken Stadt der immer stärker geworden
ist mit den moralischen Werten
von Islam und und Orthodoxie vom
Christentum und Islam wir sind offen für
alle für die russische Kultur und die
russischen Menschen
Interventionen gab die Wirren wurden
genutzt und auch nach 1917 die Unruhen
ja es ist aber gescheitert und die
reicht immer Russlands
hatte der Westen ja doch Ende des 20
Jahrhunderts erreicht als der Staat
zerstört war damals wurden wir als
Freunde verpartner bezeichnet aber in
Wahrheit haben sie uns als Kolonie
gesehen und sie haben
große Unmengen von Dollarn aus dem Land
gepumpt mit unterschiedlichen schämen
aber wir wissen das alles wir haben das
nicht vergessen und in diesen Tagen ist
es so dass die Menschen nicht ihre
sonnensupporigin drin jetzt grüne ganz
nicht dafür ausgesprochen haben dass Sie
unsere historische Einheit wieder
herstellen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
die westlichen Länder sagen schon seit
Jahrhunderten dass sie anderen Völkern
Freihandel Demokratie bringen aber es
ist alles genau umgekehrt statt
Demokratie wird unterdrückt und
ausgebeutet statt Freiheit werden
Menschen versklavt und Gewalt
untergeordnet das ist eine unipolare
Weltordnung antidemokratisch und nicht
frei es ist voller Lügen und
heuchlerisch durch und durch
die USA haben zweimal Atomwaffen
angewendet sie haben japanische Städte
Hiroshima und mangasaki zerstört im
übrigen haben sie auch
Präzedenzfall geschaffen die USA haben
zusammen mit den Briten in Ruinen gelegt
ohne militärische Gründe während des
Zweiten Weltkrieges solche Städte wie
Köln Hamburg Dresden und viele andere
deutsche Städte und das war demonstrativ
ohne ich sage es noch einmal ohne
militärische Notwendigkeit das Ziel war
ganz klar es gab nur ein Ziel genauso
wie die Atomwaffen in Japan eine
schüchterung unser Land und auch die
ganze Welt sollte eingeschüchtert werden
die USA haben eine schreckliche Spur
gelegt in Korea in Vietnam sie haben
bombardiert sie haben Napalm und
chemische Waffen eingesetzt bis heute
besetzen sie Deutschland Japan die
Republik Korea und auch viele andere
Länder und dabei nennen sie sie zynisch
gleichberechtig gleichberecht an der
unionspartner und Verbündete was ist es
denn für Verbündete die ganze Welt weiß
doch dass hinter der Führung dieser
Länder hinter den führenden Politikern
dass sie abgehört werden nicht nur in
ihren Diensträumen sondern auch in ihrem
privaten wohnen Häusern das ist doch
eine Schande für diejenigen die das tun
und diejenigen die wie Sklaven schweigen
und diese frecher diese Dreistigkeit
schlucken
die Befehle zu ihren vasalen bezeichnen
sie als Euro atlantische Union sie
veranstalten Experimente an lebenden
Menschen zum Beispiel auch in der
Ukraine bezeichnen selbst medizinischen
Experimente ihre zerstörende Politik
Plünderung Zerstörung damit haben sie
heute große Migrationsströme
hervorgebracht viele
sterben während sie versuchen nach
Europa zu kommen eben gerade wird
Getreide aus der Ukraine geschafft wohin
geht dieses Getreide sie sagen sie
garantieren die Lebensmittelsicherheit
für die ärmsten Länder aber wohin geht
das das geht doch in die europäischen
Länder dieses Getreide fünf Prozent nur
ist
in die ärmsten Länder der Welt gegangen
wieder einmal ist das Betrug und direkte
Lügen
die amerikanische Elite nutzt im Grunde
die tragöde dieser Menschen aus um ihre
Wettbewerbe zu schwächen für die
Zerstörung von nationalen Staaten das
betrifft auch Europa das betrifft die
Identität Frankreichs Italiens Spaniens
anderer Länder mit einer Jahrhunderte
alten Geschichte Washington fordert
immer neue Sanktionen gegen Russland sie
fordern immer neue Sanktionen und viele
europäische Politiker finden sich damit
ab sie nicken das ab sie verstehen doch
ganz klar dass die USA darauf drücken
dass die EU sich von russischen
energieträgerne lossagt und das führt zu
den Industrialisierung Europas damit sie
den europäischen Markt komplett
beherrschen können Sie verstehen das
doch alles diese europäischen Olive
Eliten sie verstehen das sehr gut aber
sie ziehen es vor fremden Interessen zu
dienen das ist kein lakaientum sondern
ein Verrat an der eigenen Heimat aber
das ist ihre Angelegenheit aber die
Angelsachsen begnügen sich nicht mehr
mit Sanktionen es geht schon so
diversionen das ist eine Tatsache es
gibt ja schon Explosionen in den
Gaspipelines in der Ostsee sie zerstören
im Grunde schon gesamt die
gesamteuropäische Infrastruktur ist es
doch offensichtlich für wen das von
Nutzen ist naja derjenige hat das
gemacht für den das eben von Nutzen ist
der das Diktat der USA basiert auf
grober Gewalt und vorher schaffte
manchmal ist es schön verpackt manchmal
kommt das aber auch ohne Verpackung
daher aber das ist doch ganz klar die
Herrschaft des mächtigen und von daher
rührt auch
die Präsenz von
Militärstützpunkten die Erweiterung der
NATO es werden neue militärische
Bündnisse geschmiedet viele andere man
arbeitet auch ganz aktiv
zwischen Washington zu Tokio alle
Staaten die wahre strategische
Souveränität haben wollen und die der
westliche Hegemonie eine Herausforderung
sein können werden gleichzeitig als
Feinde eingestuft das sind die
Prinzipien auf denen die militärische
doktrinosaunato aufbaut und das
erfordert eine totale Dominanz ihre
neo-niale Pläne werden genauso
heuchlerisch präsentiert
sie decken das mit dem Wort Liebe zum
Frieden
das ist aber hohen und diese Begriffe
wandern aus einer Strategie in den
nächsten bedeutenden Grunde aber nur
eines die Untergrabung von allen
souveränenzentren der Entwicklung wir
haben ja schon gehört von Eindämmung
Chinas Russlands und ich vermute mal das
auch andere Länder Lateinamerika Amerika
Asien im Nahen Osten schon auf der Liste
stehen und auch ihre Partner und
Verbündete der USA aber wir wissen ja
wenn sie irgendetwas nicht mögen dann
können Sie auch gegen Verbündete
Sanktionen einführen gegen eine Bank
oder andere Banken gegen
unterschiedliche Unternehmen das ist
doch gängige Praxis und das wird auch
weitergehen
sie zielen auf alle Arten darunter auch
unsere nächsten Nachbar und die GUS
starten aber der Westen hat ja ganz klar
Wunsch die halten Wunsche für Realität
sie haben angenommen dass sie wieder
einmal nach ihrem Kommando die ganze
Welt unterordnen können aber solche
freudigen Perspektiven erregen nicht
jedermannsfreude
von anderen und traditionellen
Beziehungen
Mehrheit von den Völkern weigert sich
das anzunehmen die entscheiden sich für
den vernünftigen Weg der Zusammenarbeit
einen Weg nicht der niederbeugung Westen
gegenüber aber das hat der Westen nicht
erwartet sie haben sich einfach gewohnt
dass es mit chantage und mit der
Einschüchterung funktioniert und sie
belohnen sich selbst dass es immer so
funktionieren wird als ob es immer so
wäre dass man eingesperrt wäre in der
Vergangenheit das ist ein
Verlust von der selbst Exklusivität
selbst Exklusivität das kann man da kann
man darüber kann man sich nur wundern
aber ein informations-hunger im Westen
wurde ertrunken im Ozean von Fakes und
Lügen indem man extrem aggressive
Propaganda anwendet die Lügen was das
Zeug hält die Lügen so mehr so wie
Goebbels je mehr Lüge desto besser
und aber die Menschen kann man nicht mit
gedruckten Euro 1.000 von Euros
betrügen die sozialen Netze vom Westen
sind nicht dazu da um die Wärme die
Häuser zu bringen das ist natürlich ganz
wichtig aber nicht weniger wichtig was
ich gerade angesprochen wird mit den mit
Papier kann kriegt man keinen Satz das
ist Sicherheit sind keine Lebensmittel
und mit diesen aufgeblasenen
aufgeblasenen wie heißt das noch mal
Kapitalisierung kann man auch keinen
kein Haus warm machen die Energieträger
das Rossmann damit die Häuser warm sind
deswegen die Politik auch in Europa die
Politiker müssen ihre
begrünen Bürger
überzeugen sich werbeanze ziehen auch zu
Hause weniger zu essen und dann sagen
Sie warum wieso langsam sind sie
fallweise Feinde Extremisten
ja dann sagt man mehr Russland wäre
schuld an eurem leiden ja aber die Lügen
die schon wieder was ich noch mal
unterstreichen möchte es gibt alle
Gründe zu vermoden dass die westlichen
Eliten nicht in beabsichtigt sind einen
Ausweg aus der energetischen und anderen
Krisen auszuwenden weil die Krise ist
verursacht von durch deren langjährige
Politik die wollen aber dennoch kein
Ausweg daraus suchen wollen
nur aber
diese Ungerechtigkeit
wir haben eine Vermutung die wollen
deren für gewohnte wegen nutzen
und da gibt es ein Widerspruch am Anfang
des 20 Jahrhunderts ist der Westen durch
den zweiten weltlichen Krieg Zweiten
Weltkrieg rausgegangen die USA das hat
den USA ist versucht geholfen aus der
großen Depression rauszukommen und die
Macht davon Dollar aus der größten
Währung weltweit zu beschäftigen zu
bestätigen in den 1980er Jahren hat der
Westen wieder eine große Krise erlebt
aber der westenrat zu überlebt durch
Aneignung von Ressourcen und Erbe von
den zerfallenden und jetzt zerfallenen
Sowjetunion das ist mit Tatsache um
jetzt aus dieser nächsten
widerspruchskette rauszukommen
brauchen Sie ein gebrochenes Russland
andere Staaten die ein souveränen Weg
finden ist nicht erlauben die anderen
auszurauben
genau die brauchen es nur um ihre Löcher
zu stopfen wenn es nicht passiert
schließlich nicht aus weil die wollen
dann es zum Kollaps führen das kann ich
nicht ausschließen dass die es machen
wollen
um Gott bewahre wollen die zu einer
bestimmten
Formel führen Krieg wird alles
abschreiben Russland versteht ihre
Verantwortung vor der Welt
Öffentlichkeit und wird alles tun um
diese heißen Köpfe zur Ruhe zu bringen
diese dieses neue koloniale Modell was
wir haben ist
dem Ende geweiht aber die realen Herren
davor werden bis zum letzten daran
kleben wir wissen das weil die einfach
nicht zur Welt anzubieten haben außer
diesem Raumsystem der Welt gegenüber die
wollen die Milliarden von Menschen dem
größten von Menschheit nicht akzeptieren
für Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung damit
sie ihre Zukunft selbst bestimmen das
wollen die einfach nicht tun momentan
lehnen sie alle momentan alle
moralischen Werte ab für was Religion
und Familie anbelangt lasst uns die ganz
einfachen Anfragen für sich selbst
beantworten ich spreche jetzt alle
Bürger des Landes an nicht nur die ich
hier gerade im Salz sitzen sondern an
alle Bürger Russlands wollen wir etwa
dass wir hier in unserem Land in
Russland anstatt Mama und Papa
Eltern wollen wir Eltern Teil 1 Eltern
Teil 2 seid ihr bekloppt wollen wir das
haben wollen wir in unseren Schulen von
den Grundschule an dass die Kinder
aufgedrückt bekommen die dir Gradierung
die zur Aussterben führt wollen wir das
eingeprägt wollen dass es kein Mann und
Frau gibt sondern es gibt noch einen
anderen gender
dass man sich auch operieren kann um
Geschlecht zu wechseln wollen wir das
etwa für unser Land und für unsere
Kinder nein das ist für uns nicht
akzeptierbar nicht annehmbar wir haben
eine andere unserer Zukunft die Diktatur
von westlichen Eliten ist Gerichte gegen
alle Gesellschaften unter anderem auch
gegen die westlichen Gesellschaften das
ist eine Herausforderung an alle diese
Ablehnung von allem Menschen an
Tradition drin ist die Unterdrückung von
Freiheit dieser Unterdrückung wird
selbst zur Religion und zum einem
gewissen Satanismus
jesus hat gesprochen in seiner
Bergpredigt an dem früchter von seiner
Predigt erkennt er die und diese Früchte
sehen wir schon nicht nur in unserem
Land das sehen wir in allen Ländern
für viele Menschen auch auch im selben
Westen im Westen selbst wir sind
eingetreten in die Stadion von von
evolutionären Verwandlungen es gibt neue
Zentren der Entwicklungen geben diese
neue Zentren werden die Mehrheit ich
wiederhole die Mehrheit der
Weltöffentlichkeit vortreten die nicht
nur ihre Werte vertreten wollen sondern
ist auch verteidigen wollen und in
dieser
monopolarität ist der eigentliche Wert
und die eigentliche Freiheit der neuen
Welt deren Werte und deren Recht auf auf
eigene Entwicklung auf eine harmonische
Entwicklung für die Zukunft in der
ganzen Welt unter anderem in Europa in
den USA wie ich schon gesagt habe haben
wir viele Menschen die gleich denken wie
und gleich fühlen wir wir versehen und
wir spüren deren Unterstützung ganz
viele Gesellschaften entwickeln sich
schon nach ihrem antikolonialen
freiherrlichen Weg gegen die monopolare
Entwicklung also wir müssen nur zu
unterstützen diese Kräfte werden die
Zukunft bestimmen und die geopolitische
Realität sehr geehrte Freunde heute
kämpfen wir um
Freien und friedlichen Weg vor allem für
uns selbst für Russland dafür dass
Russland und die disputie für immer in
der Vergangenheit bleiben ich bin sicher
die Völker verstehen dass die Politik so
gebaut ist dass
es geht nicht um die Unterdrückung von
anderen Völkern und Kulturen es ist
verbrecherisch
wir müssen diese schlimme Seite der
Geschichte umwandeln also dieser Umbruch
der westlichen Hegemonie ist schon
angesetzt und ist nicht wieder Gerber
so wie früher wird das nie sein
Schlachtfeld zu dem uns Geschichte und
Schicksal gerufen hat das ist ein Kampf
um unser Volk um großes historisches
Russland
[Applaus]
ein großes historisches Russland für
zukünftige Generation für unsere
Enkelkinder Kinder und Urenkel dafür
müssen wir sieversklaverei schützen und
verteidigen vor fürchterlichen
Experimente die darauf zielen dass ihr
Bewusstsein und ihre Seele zerstört
werden heute kämpfen wir damit niemand
niemals daran denken könnte dass
Russland unsere Sprache unser Volk
unsere Kultur dass man das alles einfach
nehmen und aus der Geschichte tilgen
könnte heute brauchen wir eine
Konsolidierung der gesamten Gesellschaft
und die Grundlage dieser Einigkeit kann
nur Souveränität seine Freiheit
Schaffenskraft und Gerechtigkeit unsere
Werte das ist die Liebe zum Menschen
Mitgefühl und ich möchte meine Rede mit
den Worten eines echten Patrioten
schließen Ivan Alexandra Witsch Alien
wenn ich
der Meinung bin das Russland meine
Heimat ist dann bedeutet das dass ich
russisch Liebe dass ich russisch denke
und Liebe dass ich russisch spreche und
singe dass sich russisch Glaube an die
internen Kräfte des Volkes
das der Geist des Volkes ist mein Geist
ihr Schicksal ist mein Schicksal die
Leiden ist meine Not das Aufblühen ist
meine Freude
und hinter diesen Worten steckt eine
große geistige Wahl und in über tausend
Jahre der russischen Staatlichkeit
folgten viele Generationen unserer Ahnen
heute ist diese Wahl an uns
die Bürger in Donezk in luganski in den
Volksrepubliken haben diese Wahl
getroffen ähnliche
saporicia diese Menschen haben sich
entschieden mit ihrem Volk zu sein mit
ihrer Heimat zusammen zu sein ihr
Schicksals zuteilen zusammen mit ihr zu
siegen hinter uns steht die Wahrheit
hinter uns steht Russland
das war also der russische markthaber
Wladimir Putin mit seiner Ansprache
vermutlich wird es dann jetzt gleich zu
Unterzeichnung der sogenannten
annexionsurkunden kommen die sogenannten
Führer der vier Regionen der Ukraine
über die ja hier heute entschieden
werden soll sind anwesend und vermutlich
wird es gleich eben die Unterzeichnung
gegeben es sprach der Mann übrigens der
ein
völkerrechtswidrigen Vernichtungskrieg
gegen die Ukraine am 24 Februar hat
begonnen hat und
durchführt schwer zu ertragen erledivis
oder ja in der Tat das war
eine Variation von George Orwells neu
sprechen aber vielleicht haben wir
gleichzeitig wir dürfen mal kurz schauen
weil jetzt treten nämlich nach vorne die
vier Vertreter der
aufzunehmenden Gebiete der eroberten
Gebiete Leonid passeschnig aus der
Region lochansk den ist puschin aus dann
jetzt Vladimir
Putin unterschreibt zuerst
und damit ist der Beitritt dann
vollzogen
es kommt dann noch formal eine Prüfung
durch das Verfassungsgericht und auch
noch eine Abstimmung in beiden Kammern
des russischen Parlaments so lange
wollten diese vier Herren auch in Moskau
bleiben um die ganze Prozedur bis zum
finalen Punkt mitzuerleben und
vielleicht ist interessant auch noch mal
zu erwähnen dass insgesamt glaube ich 90
Prozent der Verwaltungen in diesen
fehlgebieten keine ukrainischen
Staatsbürger sind sondern aus Russland
kommen das sollte man auch mal sagen das
unterstreicht den besatzerstatus
natürlich
geweigert haben weggelaufen sind und
nicht bereit waren zur kollaborieren mit
dem Besatzern
also Sie haben ja vorhin schon
angefangen zu analysieren was wir da
gehört haben ja das war wieder eine
verrückte Mischung wie ich fand aus
sozusagen hobbyhistorischen Analysen und
weltpolitischen Ambitionen die da Putin
vorgetragen hat oder ja lassen wir
einfach mal anfangen mit der Holz die
auch zu Beginn der Rede deutlich wurde
wenn Putin zum Beispiel sagt mit dieser
diesen Schutz dieser vier Region der
Aufnahme in die Russische Föderation
werde man doch der UNO Kater gerecht die
er das Selbstbestimmungsrecht der Völker
auf ihre Fahnen geschrieben habe ich
meine das muss man erstmal hinkriegen
ohne Alkohol zu werden denn die UNO
weiter gerade jetzt eine Resolution
vorbereitet um genau das zu verurteilen
was sie für buterisch hat das auch noch
mal als null und nichtig bezeichnet aber
das ist eine Rede natürlich
andersrussische Volk an die russische
Bevölkerung und die lebt halt seit 22
Jahren in einer Welt der Propaganda in
einer
Alternativen Welt wenn Sie so wollen wir
können die Rede mal kurz noch mal
durchscannen der rote Faden ist völlig
klar Russland führt einen heroischen
Abwehrkampf gegen den aggressiven
imperialistischen hegemonen USA
die Vorhaben Russland auch zum wasaden
zu machen wie viele viele andere Staaten
die auch genannt hat und er hat auch
sehr ausführlich natürlich die westliche
Kolonialgeschichte aufgezählt da gibt es
ja auch wenig zu beschönen da hat er
angefangen mit Sklavenhandel er hat die
Bomben in Hiroshima und Nagasaki erwähnt
Vietnam napal und so weiter er hat
natürlich dieses Bild des aggressiven
impalistischen Westens sehr weit
ausgemalt und dann gibt es aber immer
wieder stellen wo ich selbst sage boah
wie kriegt er das über die Lippen zum
Beispiel wenn er sagt die USA wollen
eine völlige d-industrialisierung
Europas die haben sich dagegen gewehrt
dass die Europäer unsere preiswerte
Energie
einsetzen ich meine er hat uns gerade
selbstbestätige wissen und was auch
nicht gesagt hat ist es eher Putin mit
seinen Truppen eine Land überfallen hat
das mehr als 30 Jahre unabhängig war und
völlig unabhängig vor allem von Russland
war jetzt ist dieses diese prozedon
offensichtlich beendet Putin stellt sich
noch mal auf shellcans mit diesen
Männern aus diesen Regionen der Ukraine
sie haben es beschrieben helle lischkis
jetzt gibt es noch das eine oder andere
an formalen Akten aber damit ist
sozusagen russland hat diese Region als
russisch annektiert und von dem Moment
an quasi das hat Putin ja auch gesagt
betrachtet Russland das als sein
Territorium genau wir sollten auch
erwähnen es gab jetzt nicht die große
Überraschung in der Rede es war ja
spekuliert worden sagte jetzt noch etwas
weiter eskalieren das wird er den Krieg
erklären einer der nicht er hat
wiederholt Russland sei bereit dieses
Territorium zu verteidigen wie das
ursprüngliche Russland das ist eine
Wiederholung Bedrohung wenn Ukraine wenn
Truppen der Ukraine versuchen diese
Gebiete zurückzuerobern zu befreien aus
Kiel Übersicht dann wäre das sofort
verbunden mit dem Einsatz aller
möglichen Waffen
wir wissen da gibt es inzwischen
aufgerichtet Diskussionen würde er
wirklich zu einer taktischen Atomwaffe
greifen oder zu chemischen oder
biologischen Waffen das wissen wir alles
nicht das hat ja hier in einem Satz noch
mal betont aber nicht so massiv wenn man
hätte erwarten können sondern er hat ein
Großteil seiner Energie darauf verwandt
die gefährliche aggressive Energie des
amerikanischen
internismus darzustellen die eben das
tausendjährige Russland auf die Knie
ziehen zwingen will sich der russischen
Rohstoff
bemächtigen möchte und jetzt sehen
Zusammenschluss wunderbar aus Sicht weil
die mir Putin das ist übrigens nicht
ungefährlich für die anderen Herren
verboten vielleicht selber auch weil
hören heute aus Carson dass dort der
Sicherheitschef von den von den
Ukrainern
sozusagen getötet wurde das Haus wurde
bombardiert das heißt diese Männer Leben
durchaus gefährlich oder ja natürlich
wir sprachen ja auch bereits über die
teilweise erstaunlichen Erfolge der
Ukraine nehmen wir mal Herr son auch da
ist die Lage ja sehr sehr eng geworden
für die Russen die Ukraine haben
Nachschubwege abgeschnitten Brücken
gesprengt da ist eine größere Einheit
wirklich in sehr prekärer Lage und Putin
hat sich in den letzten Tagen so
zahlreiche Meldungen wirklich
eingemischt ins militärische während die
eigene Militärs vorschlagen wir ziehen
uns über den Nepot zurück Richtung Krim
um da eine stabile Abwehrfront
aufzubauen behaart Putin offensicht
darauf dass Herr Sonn gehalten wird es
ist ein symbolisches
erobertes Gebiet für ihn natürlich das
könnte sein aber dass dass das
vielleicht mit einem hohen Preis
verbunden ist dieser der russischen
Truppen wenn das was uns viele
Militärexperten sagen zutrifft nämlich
dass sie in einer ganz schon schwierigen
Lage sind also die Veranstaltung
jedenfalls innen im Kreml ist jetzt
beendet das internationale Signal ist
auch von dort schon wieder abgestellt
worden man sollte vielleicht noch
erwähnen es soll draußen
vor dem Kreml auf dem Roten Platz ein
großes Konzert Volksfest geben man
versucht das Ganze dann noch jetzt
sozusagen zu feiern und zu zelebrieren
diese Erweiterung des russischen
Staatsgebildes er sagte Putin die
schlimme Seite der Geschichte umwandeln
das sei sein Ziel es geht es um den
Kampf um unser Volk das große
historische Russland glauben die das die
Russen ja das ist nun schwierig zu sagen
wer von diesen schätzungsweise 2000
Menschen im Saal also der Nomenklatura
das wirklich glaubt ich glaube eher eine
kleine Zahl
es ist ja wirklich so dass niemand wagt
öffentlich laut zu widersprechen Putin
hat da eine sehr extreme historische
Vision in den Raum gestellt er will das
stolze Russland in seiner drei Einigkeit
oder Dreifaltigkeit fast schon dass Gott
gewollte wieder zusammenführen nämlich
groß Russland Weißrussland und kleinen
Russland sprich Ukraine das ist offenbar
sein brennender Wunsch dass im Alter
noch hinzukriegen und da riskiert er
jetzt ja wahnsinnig viel mehr gesehen
haben die ökonomischen Folgen und auch
politischen Folgen für sein Land shining
ihm fast egal zu sein denn wir können ja
reden über was wir wollen allein jetzt
dass Manöver uns das Gas abzustellen und
eventuell auch die Pipelines gesprengt
zu haben das ist letztlich das Aus für
Gazprom also schadet seinem Land ja
extremst mit dem was er da tust dieser
Revanchismus dieser Neo Imperialismus
uns jetzt mal so zu formulieren den er
da jetzt noch mal sozusagen rhetorisch
versucht hat
studieren und die Praxis sieht ja auch
so aus mit der Okkupation dieser Region
der Ukraine hatte das versteckt die
letzten 20 Jahre bis hin zu dem Tag an
dem beschlossen wurde diese Pipeline
North Stream 2 zu bauen wie sie kennen
auch in ändern sich an die Bilder mit
den deutschen Politikern in dem
Zusammenhang hat er das verschleiert
versteckt oder ist es sozusagen erst in
den letzten Jahren in ihm geboren worden
diese verrückten Ideen nein er hat ja
immer schon ähnliche Ideen geäußert nur
haben wir im Westen uns nicht vorstellen
können dass er das in die Tat umsetzt
bis 2014 ich meine das ist für mich der
Zeitpunkt wo uns eben Europa aber es ist
recht in Berlin die Ausreden endgültig
ausgehen da hat er gezeigt er ist
willens und bereit mit militärischer
Gewalt zu annektieren einen Teil eines
Nachbarstaates einen Krieg zu entfesseln
der
1415.000 Menschen das Leben gekostet hat
und die Reaktion der Europäer das wissen
sie und erinnern Sie wahrscheinlich
pflaumenweiche Sanktionen das war ein
einreisesperren für unbekannte Figuren
und und das war nichts was Putin auch
nur annähernd beeindrucken konnte im
Gegenteil dann hat Sigmar Gabriel
vorneweg mit Hilfe von Gerhard Schröder
North Stream 2 auf die Schiene gebracht
und das war das Geschenk das Putin
unbedingt haben wollte also da sehe ich
einen dramatischen historischen Fehler
in ein Versagen wir haben ihn ermutigt
und glaube ich nur so kann man erklären
dass er jetzt dieses ganz große Ding
gewagt hat
ja mit dieser heutigen Erklärung mit
dieser Unterschrift definiert ja
Russland diese Region als zu sich
gehörend wie die Ukrainer reagieren des
wissen wir sie befreien offensichtlich
zur Stunde Liman vermutlich wird es die
Ukraine auch noch anspornen was der da
heute im Kreml erzählt hat wie sollte
Berlin darauf reagieren ja genau wie
Berlin auch glaube ich reagiert indem
man das bezeichnet als scheinreferenten
das ist ja fast schon zu nett das Wort
das ist eine eine annektionsfahrt die da
aufgeführt wird aber das wird ja in
Berlin auch deutlich gemacht und das ist
korrekt so die Sprache jetzt über 2014
und 2015 da hat Berlin natürlich ganz
andere Töne von sich gegeben und da
liegt für mich eine Wurzel auch für sein
Verhalten jetzt er hat vermutlich auch
wiederum den den Widerstand der Europäer
unterschätzt er hat gedacht das geht
noch mal wieder gut die werden laut
protestieren und die Backen aufblasen
aber dann letztlich wird es weitergehen
irgendwie und das ist Gott sei Dank
nicht der Fall und Sie haben ja schon
schon erläutert wie er den Widerstand
und den Widerstands Geist und die Kraft
der Ukraine unterstützt hat wir haben ja
vorhin den ukrainischen Präsidenten
selenski schon mal angespielt bevor dann
Putin live kam und wir wollen das jetzt
ihnen noch mal einspielen liebe
Zuschauer also wie gesagt in seiner
Ansprache in der Nacht hat er Präsident
der Ukraine sich ein ausdrücklich an die
kaukasischen Minderheiten an die
kaukasischen Ethnien in Russland gewandt
ich befinde mich gerade in dem Teil
Kiews wo
1860 ein Held dargestanz lebte und das
ganzen Kaukasus ihm
wie Sie sehen kann die Ukraine eure
Helden und ihre Helden würdigen wir
behalten das Andenken an die Orte die
die Kulturen unserer Völker
zusammengebracht haben das ist das
Epizentrum unserer Hauptstadt
eine der hunderte Städten der Ukraine
gegen die die russische Regierung
Raketen richtet Bomben und auch Truppen
der Kaukasus weiß was das bedeutet der
Kaukasus hat das schon gesehen
schon 218 Tage verteidigen wir uns gegen
die